so some big news happened today in the
movie world in the nerd world in the
life world in the holy crap finally
world I call that world star wars
episode 7 news guess who was at the
Disney office today maybe he has a part
in the movie you know what I saw this
actress walking around the Disney studio
she might be in Star Wars 7 guess what I
heard about Star Wars 7 and none of its
ever factual very rarely do we ever have
a hard piece of something to talk about
and what do you know
the official cast for the film has been
announced and it includes Harrison Ford
Mark Hamill Carrie Fisher Anthony
Daniels Peter Mayhew Kenny Baker and a
lot of other people that are cool too
but um the original cast is in the new
Star Wars movie
so yeah that's yeah I already did my
fanboying off camera so I could appear
semi-professional in this video for the
purpose of looking like I have an idea
of what I'm talking about but in reality
I'm just like I'm losing credibility by
the minute there's also a lot of really
cool new actors added to this cast for
one Andy Serkis is in it Max von Sydow
John boyega from attack the block
another great addition to the cast I'm
excited about is Oscar Isaac how awesome
is that the guy from drive inside Lewin
Davis this is a very good actor and I'm
extremely excited to see him in this
world I love the fact that Kenny Baker
will actually be r2d2 because you know
what that tells me there's not going to
be some stupid CGI r2d2 wheeling around
it's actually gonna be a man in the can
activating that and doing it and that is
just fantastic I don't know if Anthony
Daniels will actually be in the suit of
c-3po but he will definitely provide the
voice receive through Pio and that is
awesome in fact the c-3po and r2d2 are
in the movie and Peter Mayhew is gonna
be Chewbacca this is all very cool for
me now this is my fanboy side this is me
going oh my gosh these are the things I
grew up on I wore out these VHS tapes I
watched them over and over again they're
incredible we have a director who
actually understands this world and who
understands the idea of creating
practical events not just a whole bunch
of CGI whoo real
understands fast-paced filmmaking who
was more inspired by Star Wars as a
child than Star Trek and he made two
really good Star Trek movies in my
opinion so I'm looking forward to his
view of the new Star Wars films I am
pumped out of my mind to see what these
films bring I love the fact that the
original cast is gonna be returning I
also heard that Mark Hamill and Carrie
Fisher heaven barked upon a very serious
diet and stunt training regimen which is
good because Harrison Ford's been in
shape forever he always looks good
but I was like you know Mark Hamill you
know I love the guy but you're gonna
have to lose some weight you're gonna be
a badass Jedi now some of the things
I've heard is that some people are
complaining there's not enough women in
the cast now for one we don't know the
whole cast and for two there are two
confirmed females in the cast an actress
named Carrie Fisher for a one who just
so happens to be main character in the
movie if I was Carrie Fisher I'd be a
little offended I'd be like I'm a woman
I'm in the movie I'm a girl another
actress named Daisy Ridley is gonna be
in the movie so there are women in the
film and this is just the confirmed
starting cast we don't know what the
whole cast is gonna be it just people
are always finding something to be upset
about it doesn't matter how cool or
awesome an announcement is or how
amazing something is someone will find
something go I don't like that dumb I'm
gonna complain about it through an
internet comment because that's what I
do
nevertheless what I am is optimistic
because I am an optimist and I'm excited
for a great movie and I am truly hoping
we're gonna get another Star Wars
trilogy for the history books and it's
looking like it has the great
possibility of being that way because we
have people behind and in front of the
camera who care and who are talented and
are good at what they do and understand
the fan perspective now especially after
the prequels because something the
prequels did not have is the prequels
already existing now that we have the
prequels existing they're like we know
what not to do let's not do that again
let's do something else and make it the
way it should be use practical effects
makeup creatures real awesome stunt work
have real places not just a giant
green-screen environment in which you're
told to do it faster and with more
intensity over and over again never mind
okay I'm getting
tangent here and let's just be
optimistic about Star Wars Episode seven
the original Casas and oh my god guys
what are your thoughts on this awesome
movie news let me know below and as
always thank you so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck in the heist